Oh God
it's like eating a pimple oh you don't
want me to eat sushi in this because I
probably won't fall fish can be really
squishy it's a little too chewy for me
is she something about textures really
disgusts me
I hate tuna Hagen hate fish burgers
don't like squash bacon onion sushi I
don't like green beans peppers zucchini
bananas when people call me a picky
eater it makes me think that I'm a snob
but I'm not a snob I just like the foods
that I like look if the tofu mushroom
ago now mushrooms should only be
consumed by Marco you know rubberband
mushroom is that bad I thought I hated
mushrooms usually after my fitness class
I get a bagel with cream cheese today
I'm gonna be bent wrist and get like
turkey bacon
it's not disgusting but it's not good oh
that's cute
they put salad with my fried chicken
Oh smells like the ocean it smells so
disgusting no go grote feels like the
fish is trying to crawl back up my
throat and get out that was maybe the
worst thing I've ever put in my mouth I
almost threw up I would not give this to
a rat in my apartment to kill that
doesn't belong in the Merrill it's like
I'm eating my own tongue
it's like Angry glue it does not want to
be swallowed all right being alive at
the hummus tahini and getting green the
absolute worst color for food I
conquered it
I conquered none of it's in the trash
friends have always made fun of me
because I've never had a tuna melt
I would never get this again Indian food
the craziest thing about this is I don't
even know what I have let's try it I
might finish it like that did yesterday
see in your food very bad I don't know
what it is again don't know what it is
my name back
noise
I spit it out
Oh God I almost threw up alcohol won't
even get rid of booties I need like five
more starts singer
it tastes like butter I didn't really
taste the snail
it wasn't bad it doesn't taste that much
different than any other meat covered in
butter so it's actually okay
I was very proud of myself that was
maybe the hardest thing I've ever done
in my life and I told my whole family
about it they were all very proud I'm
really happy that I tried a bunch of new
foods I think too often in life we get
stuck in our own routines I want to
continue trying new foods if I took
anything away from this week it would be
that I shouldn't let my experiences as a
kid affect my palate as an adult my
advice to picky eaters just stick to
what you're used to except for Indian
food try Indian food Indian food is so
good about you India